I want to talk about this neighborhood I
want to talk about this neighborhood in
which this story is said what it means
to you and what it means to your
creative collaborator TELRIC Randy so
describe this world and how you came to
bring it to the screen what it means to
you yeah so Liberty City is the
neighborhood in Miami where myself and
Tyrell grew up it's kind of like the
Compton or south-central of LA it's sort
of the same neighborhood in Miami and
it's interesting because I don't talk
about being from there a lot and so not
a lot of people knew that aspect of my
biography and Terrell mcrainey who's a
MacArthur Genius playwright he grew up
in the same place and so when he was
graduating from DePaul undergrad in 2003
as an acting fellow he was applying to
the Yale School of Drama as a playwright
and he had to do a writing sample or a
work sample and so he wrote this play
and moon like black boys with blue and
ten years later it landed on my doorstep
I like to say in my inbox I guess this
is 2013 and and it was really beautiful
because when it came to me on the line
was this isn't about you but it's about
you and what my friends meant these two
guys in Miami who knew both myself and
Terrell was that they knew about this
aspect of my biography where my mom was
addicted to crack cocaine and I don't
talk about that very much
and here's Terrell mcrainey MacArthur
playwright his mom would stick to crack
cocaine and so these guys thought well
we should get these two guys together
and have them make a film about that and
that was how it came to me I want to
talk about the first time that you guys
started talking about this project
specifically what were those initial
conversations and what were the
obstacles to turning this play into a
screenplay um well I think that as I was
telling you before Barry and I started
talking about this project in context of
a few different ideas of what could be
his sophomore film and eventually
settled on this one and what I liked
about it and I think it took Barry a
minute to figure this out was that it
was a deeply personal story to Barry
even though it was an adaptation of
somebody else's work that was
autobiographical that's both promising
and perilous isn't it well it will it
kind of happen
the way it had to happen because like
you said I thought it wasn't personal I
thought I would just hide behind Terrell
you know it's not my mom it's his mom
but in the course of writing this thing
because originally I was going to give
Terrell he's very structured notes as a
director on what I wanted to make as a
film as a director but he became a
MacArthur Genius and the process of
doing this and got way too damn busy to
actually do the writing but it was
beautiful because in those like four or
five six months we basically expressed
to each other what we thought you know
the the filmed version of this thing
could be was that scary do you which
part just to go and revisit that part of
your life that maybe you didn't talk
about it didn't share uh it was and
that's why again I thought I could hide
behind thrill
I wasn't revisiting my life I was
revisiting his life but when he went
away but that he went away exactly uh
and I went to Brussels Belgium to write
the the first draft and I wrote it in
ten days because without Sorel there I
mean the first draft I mean what you
just saw is definitely not a first draft
but it just came pouring out of me
because I realized who I didn't realize
I was putting myself fully into it
Jeremy this fine man was moderating a
Q&A at the Telluride Film Festival for
movie that you worked on called 12 years
of slave correct yeah and something
happened there that kind of got us to
this place yeah I mean it does have
there's a prior chapter which is um has
anyone seen medicine for melancholy
Barry's first from thank you person
right there thank you
well I I'm a massive fan of that film I
love that um what are the things I
remember about that film and I think we
see it again in in moonlight is is the
sort of luminosity of it the luminous
beauty of medicine from melancholy and
yet that is that somehow the delivery
system for a lot of things that are not
always beautiful and and stress some
strife and conflict so like a you know
was very captivated by that film and
wanted very much to work with Barry and
we we traded some projects my partner
and deed Ian and Plan B's our company
tried to find ways to work with Barry
and you know as sometimes happens you
know you trade ideas and you talk about
stuff and you know you don't lock it on
the one
and then you know I guess yeah 2013 we
were at the Telluride Film Festival with
12 years of slave and either like right
outside the first public screening or I
thought you know like an hour before or
something ran into buried it was like
reconnected it was lovely to see him
again
and sort of through that experience we
got a chance to start talking again
about other things and around the time I
guess shortly after the time I believe
when when a day let and Barry had
resolved that that this adaptation of in
moonlight black boys look blue was going
to be the film you know we started to
trade some material and and we got a
copy Barry sent us moonlight which as a
reader was a really memorable experience
I think the film that you just saw is um
you know some very very unique
combination of of something quite epic
something quite grand and its ambitions
and in its desire to speak to like you
know universals of human experience and
you know questions of how we grow in
time and what happens between the cuts
and things like that
and yet for that it sacrifices none of
the intimacy and and tenderness and and
and its unashamed and incredibly brave
about about its emotional depth and and
what it's going for emotionally and the
script had those qualities and we we
just said that we would like to try and
be involved and luckily for us daelin
Barry um you know welcomed Plan B into
the equation and here we are and here is
an amazing group of actors as well and
and you all should know Janelle this is
your first acting role in a movie right
yes so it's a big part I'd love to hear
like how this story project came to you
and what your initial interest slash
concerns were about plain Teresa sure
well I studied acting I went to the
American Musical and Dramatic Academy in
New York City fresh out of high school
I've always wanted to be in film but I
had not read the right script until I
read moonlight Barry Jenkins I always
tell you that script
changed my life I was I said I have to
be a part of this I dropped everything
that I was doing and I said this is a
story that we need this is fresh it is
it's raw it's emotional and when I read
for Teresa instantly I felt connected to
her because I knew women in my community
who were nurturers just like Teresa you
know when I was going through things I
had that younger aunt or the older
cousin who I can go talk to and they
wouldn't judge me they were there to
support me through hard and difficult
times and the most important thing that
I wanted to to to make sure came across
was when people saw this young boy going
through all these different stages in
their lives if they could look at their
lives and when they see young people
that they know who may be going through
something similar the other the outcast
the one who was oftentimes bullied or
discriminated against because of their
sexual orientation or the color of their
skin or their gender if they came in
contact with that person Teresa is an
example of how you treat them Naomi what
were your reservations and how to bury
work you through those concerns my
reservations were twofold really and
first of all I have always tried to I
think as an actor you don't have very
much power in the sense that you're not
producing the material you're not
writing it you're not editing it and so
I think one of the few areas where you
really do have power is in your choices
so I think
choices are incredibly important and
I've always been very careful in my
choices because I was raised by a very
strong intelligent capable woman my
mother who I really respect and admire
and I want to represent women like that
so I've always thought I want to portray
positive images of women in general and
black women in particular and I drew the
line at crack addiction and then I got
presented with this incredible script we
just sent me into a tailspin and so that
was one of my dilemmas and then the
other thing was I don't drink alcohol I
don't smoke
I don't even drink coffee so I was
wondering how I go from me
misty total to full-blown crack
addiction and I was really apprehensive
about taking that on board and then I
spoke to Barry and if ever you're unsure
about anything don't speak to Barry
because he'll persuade you anything I
make you believe that you can achieve
anything as well which is a wonderful
quality in the director and he just
basically explained to me that this part
was you know the story
his mother's story and he wanted to tell
his story and his story necessarily
involved that of his mother and I
realized that here was someone who had
and he was emotionally invested in
ensuring that this character wasn't a
cliche wasn't a stereotype but was given
the full humanity and emotional depth
that she deserves trivanti there's
something in the casting of little back
little when black and tyronn that is
consistent to me and maybe to the
audience in terms of the way you see the
world through your eyes the way you look
at other people the what you take in
what you share her through your eyes so
I have a kind of a logistical question
before we get to a couple scenes is that
did you have a chance to talk with Alex
Hobart and Ashton Sanders about about
their work or he goes all shooting so
out of sequence you never even actually
bet Barry was actually quite adamant
about not allowing it okay see Andre and
I both were kind of trying to find some
semblance of what the
we're doing whether it be a walk or the
way they carried their head or held a
fork whatever maybe but Barry was really
adamant about not allowing us to do that
because he didn't want us to focus on
mimicking what the Hunger versions were
doing and he really wanted to show that
throughout our lives we changed so
drastically depend on what happens to us
and this person is someone who went
through so much that I guess casting
three different people really had to
push that through Barry might ask you
the last question and was there a moment
in production or watching this movie
that was hard for you to watch and do
and do you remember what scene that
might have been yeah I mean everything
working with Naomi was very difficult
because you know here's these things of
compartmentalised or even just buried
and and now and in the wrap-up to
production I kind of felt like this was
going to happen but that's an
intellectual thing but then when you're
on set and this person this beast of a
person is fully embodying your mother
it's a very intense thing so there were
things we did with Naomi that I didn't
think I would do until I was in the
moment and in the courtyard
when Ashland comes home from Teresa's
and she's like but I'm your mama ain't I
and she looks right at the audience
you know we had filmed the scene OTS OTS
blah blah blah and then I said to Naomi
because I felt like that's a moment of
transference where this kid is realizing
for the first time as you guys realized
the first time his mom's this other
person and I wanted you to feel what
that feels like and so it's just I love
you because she's on set for an hour the
inspector is opening worldwide she just
came from Mexico City and I go miss
Harris could you do that looking right
into the camera didn't warn her at all
she goes yes Barry I did all the time
with 28 days let's do it you know I only
wanted the line but I'm your mama ain't
I but we do it and I only she's a beast
she just keeps going and she walks off
and James walks off with her and they go
all the way to the front door and now
I'm like I'm in this kid's body we flip
around we do it on Ashton and I'm like
okay I got a movie you know be because
because when I feel these things move me
I can go hey crew I have been moved
let's all be moved and they're like yes
let's [ __ ] be moved and the whole
process of making this film was that way
for me that's a great story
you